o le rpr tape du poing sur la table à la
réunion de la majorité et envisage de
donner de nouvelle investiture
valéry giscard d'estaing en côte
d'ivoire le voyage de l'amitié et de la
considération
le premier chèque des caisses d'epargne
pour en l2 il sera une réalité avant la
fin du mois les femmes et la politique
c'est plus facile au gouvernement que
dans les partis
mesdemoiselles messieurs bonsoir un
accueil chaleureux voilà un terme trop
souvent galvaudé mais qui ce soir
s'applique merveilleusement à
l'hospitalité du peuple ivoirien qui
recevait en fin de matinée valéry
giscard d'estaing plus de cinq cent
mille personnes sur 20 km de parcours
entre l'aéroport et le centre d'abidjan
un jour chômé pour les habitants la
visite la plus longue de valéry giscard
d'estaing à l'étranger depuis son
accession à l'elysée cinq jours devriez
l'officiel voilà bien l'illustration de
cette coopération exemplaire dont on a
toujours parlé entre paris et abidjan
coopération rehaussée par le match
particulier sur aleris les 48 monsieur
houphouët boigny mon admiration pour
l'un des hommes d'état qui marquent
notre époque par la part qu'il a prise à
la conception et à la conduite de
transformation pacifique
la côte d'ivoire a apporté la
démonstration de ce qui peut être
réalisé par un pays en développement
dans la liberté et dans la démocratie
je veux un accueil des techno elle a dit
le président houphouët boigny
il faut que l'on t'a dit à nos amis
alors la paix fait l'objet de tant de
convoitises mais bien le moins que l'on
puisse dire c'est que le président
ivoirien
a été largement exaucé l'accueil est
absolument exceptionnelle il illustre
bien les relations sans nuages et
relations exemplaires entre la france et
la côte d'ivoire
oui vraiment depuis ce matin tout lady
marianne se sont mobilisés ont célébré
la fête de l'amitié la côte d'ivoire sur
les 30 km du parcours officiel l'accueil
a été continuellement le même die enjoué
coloré plein de musique de chants et de
vives
au total ils étaient plusieurs centaines
de milliers d abidjan certes mais aussi
beaucoup d'autres venus de la savane et
de la forêt avec les chefs des 70
ethnies et leur tribu au grand complet à
billets souvent comme presque toute la
population d'un boubou à l'effigié du
président français et de madame giscard
d'estaing pendant plus de deux heures le
chef de l'état et le président houphouët
boigny ont salué cette marée humaine
sous une chaleur rude
il fait plus de 30 degrés ici avec de ci
de là des groupes de français au milieu
de la foule
ils sont 45 milles en côte d'ivoire
coopérante ou cadres du secteur privé ce
mercredi était jour férié et chômé
les enfants des écoles ont rangé pour 48
heures leurs manuels qui leur dit que la
côte d'ivoire est un pays admirer et
piétons il étonne parce que sans atout
géographique particulier dépourvu
jusqu'à présent de ressources minières
il a réussi en s'appuyant uniquement sur
son agriculture à connaître un
développement rapide et exceptionnelle
sur le continent afrique
troisième producteur mondial de café
deuxième de cacao
réputé pour son huile de palme sont bois
son coton son caoutchouc son rythme et
puis l'industrie qui commence à se
développer avec en plus le pétrole
ce développement il le doit à un homme
félix houphouët boigny 72 ans
président depuis 1960 qu'on appelle ici
le vieux avec beaucoup de déférence
il ne doit pas une politique fondée sur
une coopération privilégiée avec la
france
premier client et premier fournisseur de
la côte d'ivoire le français est la
langue officielle parlée couramment par
les deux tiers de la population
cet accueil chaleureux marque le ton qui
prévaudra ici pendant tout le séjour
officiel du chef de l'état monsieur
giscard d'estaing et houphouët boigny
souligneront qu'il n'y a pas de
contentieux entre leurs deux pays et
qu'ils sont d'accord pour dire que
l'europe est seule garante de la liberté
en afrique et qu'il faut trouver le
moyen de lutter contre l' influence du
communisme sur le continent africain
demain le président français prononcera
un discours attendu à l'assemblée
nationale avant de partir vendredi pour
yamoussokro la ville natale de monsieur
houphouët boigny
on dit que l'accueil sera encore plus
surprenant qu ici à abidjan et nous
n'arrivons à la politique avec d'abord
cet énervement ce à la majorité un
énervement qui est venue du rpr cet
après midi à l'issue d'une nouvelle
réunion du comité de liaison de la
majorité le rpr qui considère que ses
partenaires ont rendu caducs les accords
de candidature unique puisque depuis ils
ont constitué un front électoral unis
contre lui jacques chirac vienne
s'expliquer pour claude sérillon il ya
quelques minutes à peine à toulouse nous
l'écoutons changement de tactique sur un
point particulier mais qui n'entraîne
bien la rupture de la majorité nous
avons au sein de la majorité
trois accords en quelque sorte d'accord
sur un manifeste
c'est l'essentiel puis naturellement il
n'est pas en cause
l'accord sur une sur un pacte
majoritaire c'est à dire de désistements
automatiques
il n'est pas en cause non plus et ces
fortes important naturellement et puis
il y avait un choix que nous avions fait
d'une part de primaire dans un certain
nombre de circonscriptions et d'autre
part de quelques candidatures uniques et
ceci en fonction de l'orientation
qu'avait donné le chef de l'état en
indiquant que la majorité devait être
pluraliste
c'est ceci qui a été remis en cause par
nos partenaires de façon d'ailleurs
unilatérale ce qui n'est pas très
convenable en violation des accords
qu'ils avaient signés puisqu'ils ont
voulu créer un front unique entière p r
et c'est nous le pensons une erreur que
de substituer cette tactique
d'affrontements à la tactique de
pluralisme qui était la précédente
nous en tirons pour notre part les
conséquences en donnant des investitures
supplémentaire là où jusqu'ici il était
prévu des candidatures uniques mais ça
ne remet rien en cause en ce qui
concerne l'union de la majorité
et en ce qui concerne l'application en
tous les cas par nous strictement des
engagements que nous avons pris au
niveau du pacte et au niveau du
manifeste de la majorité alors je vous
en prie ne dramatisons pas lieu de le
faire je vais au défi qui que ce soit de
dire que j'ai violé à l'accord et je
suis certain qu'en je ne veux pas
dramatiser
car nous sommes au contraire pour
l'union et ne vont pas faire donner
satisfaction à ceux qui attendent la
rupture dans la majorité
nous ne voulons donner aucun prétexte
mais il n'y absolument eu aucune
relation notre part et je mets au défi
quiconque de le prouver
je suis certain encore une fois que dans
quelques jours le dialogue va reprendre
et que nous trouverons une solution mais
alors daniel brême tout le monde dit il
ne faut pas dramatiser ce qu'il faut
dans la tv et horace et d'une cassure
une fêlure
non je crois qu'on joue pour le moment a
fait moins peur et c est ce qui est le
plus clair à laurent vraiment en fait
oui le rpr menace de mettre un candidat
là
il devait y avoir un seul porte drapeau
pour toute la majorité se faisant
évidemment il bouscule les quilles
mais à mon avis c'est plutôt une menace
et il espère faire reculer ce qu'ils
qualifient de fabricants d'un front
entière et deuxièmement il se met en
posture d'agresser et non pas
d'agresseurs car il reproche surtout à
ses partenaires d'avoir fait alliance
avec jean-jacques servan-schreiber qui a
toujours voulu la disparition des
gaullistes
alors est-ce qu'on peut comparer aux
points de la gauche non et aura le nom
est du reste monsieur soissons lui même
vient de dire qu'il espérait que la
raison prévaudra
il y a divergences sur les méthodes mais
pas sur le fond et je crois qu'on peut
déjà affirmer qu'il va y avoir beaucoup
de médiation dans tous les coins avant
le retour du président de la république
qui vous avait réuni la majorité le 7
janvier l'indiana voilà déjà un premier
thème me suis trouvée pour l'entretien
que nous accorde ce soir tout de suite
après ce journal le premier ministre
raymond barre invité par intel kabachi
alain duhamel dans le cadre de notre
émission cartes sur table raymond barre
qui bien entendu développera sur tout le
programme qu'il a annoncé à doit le
reste de la politique maintenant
alexandre sanguinetti sera samedi notre
invité dans samedi ennemi sera opposé au
socialiste michel rocard sur bien
entendu l'ensemble des perspectives
électorales
un livre de poche pas comme les autres
il coûte 5 francs ça c'est normal mais
il est signé valéry giscard d'estaing
c'est l'édition populaire de démocratie
française avec une préface inédite ce
que paraît-il je n'ai pas le droit de
vous dévoiler avant minuit alors on en
reparlera demain paul ricard
l'industriel bien connu donne sa
démission de maire du petit village de
signes près de toulon à la suite d'une
altercation avec le préfet du var pour
un problème de dépôt d'ordures et puis
revenons sur cette information que je
vous ai donné hier l'écrivain gilles
perrault
l'auteur de l' orchestre rouge
démissionne du parti socialiste pour
s'inscrire au parti communiste il n'est
pas d'accord avec la récente évolution
du parti socialiste et puis il faut
revenir aussi sur cette promotion des
femmes du gouvernement un ministre au
plus
pardon a mise de plus et puis deux
secrétaires d'état supplémentaires
personne ne s'en plaindra
surtout pas dans cette rédaction killing
des plus féminines de france parlant en
pourcentage de femmes journalistes
antenne 2 mais dès que l'on quitte le
niveau gouvernemental
le voir la réalité politique et bien d
autres
le phénomène n'est pas nouveau il n'y a
pas de femmes ou si peu aux postes de
responsabilités politiques encore
faut-il faire une exception pour les
militantes du parti communiste pourtant
les chemins de la politique en ce qui
concerne les femmes
son pavé de bonnes intentions le parti
socialiste s'est donné quatre ans pour
féminiser
il y a eu des déclarations dans ce sens
au sein des grands partis comme le tr ou
le rpr la france est composée de 52 % de
femmes la logique voudrait donc qu'elles
soient largement représenté dans les
mairies à l'assemblée nationale et au
sénat
or le pourcentage pour les deux
assemblées ne dépasse pas 4%
le pc présente 13 5% de candidates le
parti socialiste 5,7 pour cent
le parti républicain 3 8% et le rpr 1,3
pour cent
la faute à qui pour alexandre
sanguinetti qui n'est pas le seul de son
avis c'est à cause des femmes qui ne
votent pas pour les femmes on dit même
que si les 52% de femmes qui vivent en
france voulait féminiser la politique
cela se saurait depuis longtemps du côté
de certaines militantes politiques qui
attendent dans les antichambres des
partis si les femmes n'ont pas accès au
rôle de premier plan
c'est que les hommes pour la mainmise
sur l'appareil et qu'ils répugnent à
présenter leurs compagnes d'action dans
les campagnes électorales de la
misogynie primaires dit on de la part de
ces messieurs qui se cramponne à leurs
prérogatives
si les femmes se présentait elle serait
élue seulement on ne les présente pas et
si par hasard on le fait on les envoie à
l'abattoir dans des circonscriptions où
elles n'ont souvent aucune chance des
kamikazes en quelque sorte
françoise giroud qui sait de quoi elle
parle dit qu'il est plus facile en tant
que femme d'être ministre que député car
les ministres sont désignés par le
président de la république les choses
pourtant ne paraissent pas être aussi
simple
peut-on croire que les grands partis
s'il était convaincu que les femmes
soient susceptibles de réaliser des
scores égaux ou supérieurs à ceux des
hommes pourraient par seul misogynie se
passer d'atouts supplémentaires pour les
femmes ministres ou candidates imposer
les femmes
ce n'est pas une mince affaire
je crois qu'il y a eu une évolution et
que les états majors politiques ont
réellement cherché à trouver pour un
certain nombre de femmes des
circonscriptions le climat si vous
voulez est différent mais ça ne se fait
pas dans de bonnes conditions ça ne se
fait pas bon parce qu'il ya des
résistances massive qui existent encore
parce qu'on croit encore que les femmes
ne vont pas voter pour les femmes et
puis parce que compte tenu de leur vie
familiale et c'est mon pas par exemple
je n'ai pas pu accepter une
circonscription lointaine peu de sam ont
été désignés pour ces élections chez
nous comme ailleurs
l'ennui c'est que nous on peut pas
rattraper les choses en nommant des gens
au gouvernement
à deux mois des élections c'est qui peut
d'une certaine façon arrivé à masquer
certaines manquent par ailleurs d'abord
pour être candidate c'est assez
difficile
vous savez que les états majors
politiques
donne difficilement l'investiture à une
femme et quand par hasard une femme est
député on s'arrange pour faire en sorte
qu'elle soit obligée comme moi présenter
en candidat libre et on lui envoie un
parachute et qui vient d'une autre
circonscription qui à l'investiture des
quatre partis de la majorité ce qui
revient à dire que moi député sortant je
suis obligé de me présenter en candidat
indépendant
ça prouve bien quand même que les états
majors politiques ne facilite pas les
choses aux femmes
le prince aux parcours sait de quoi elle
parle elle affaires sociales et
économiques la firme allemande thyssen
retire ses billes du complexe de fos sur
mer elle avait une participation de 5%
dans la société qui exploite les
installations sidérurgiques elle la
cédera à ses partenaires français
sacilor et usinor entreprises victor
michel dépose son bilan 340 personnes
perdent leur emploi entreprises
possédaient deux usines dans la région
parisienne michel durafour chez le
premier ministre cet après-midi pour
attirer son attention sur le sort
précaire de manufrance raymond barre lui
annoncé 20 millions de francs de prêts
pour l'entreprise et puis on bat le
rappel chez volkswagen le rappel de
certains modèles golf scirocco construit
entre ou de 74 et mais 75 ces véhicules
présente un vice de fabrication qui
n'est pas vraiment dangereux mais qu'il
faut rectifier cela concerne en france
quinze mille volkswagen et puis j'ai là
entre les mains le premier chèque émis
par une caisse d'epargne c'est une
petite performance car le premier de ces
chèques officielle ne sera signé que
dans deux semaines par robert boulin
mais ça ne nous empêche pas de commencer
à en parler philippe sassier oui ce
chèque que vous venez de montrer
effectivement pour la première fois il
ya des années et des années qu'on en
parle qu'on en parle d'abord et que les
caisses d'epargne l'attend ce fameux
check et effectivement c'est le 25
janvier prochain que robert boulin le
ministre des finances va signer
officiellement le premier chèque ensuite
les caisses d'epargne notamment de
versailles de pontoise et caisse
d'epargne la région lyonnaise pour avoir
ce chéquier et puis progressivement il
serait étendue à l'ensemble des caisses
d'epargne de la france les parisiens
pourront probablement l'obtenir au mois
de septembre progressivement donc alors
est ce que tout le monde pourra posséder
ce chéquier
en principe oui mais l'écureuil le petit
animal emblème
ce n'est pas un animal prudent il ne
veut pas que de mauvais payeurs face des
trous dans son bas de laine alors il va
prendre des précautions
il faudra montrer patte blanche pour
obtenir un chèque et il faudra par
exemple déjà posséder un livret de
caisse d'épargné le fonctionnement du
compte chèque sera indépendant du
fonctionnement du livret de caisse
d'épargné il faudra prouver une certaine
stabilité dans l'emploi une certaine
stabilité dans la résidence une certaine
stabilité aussi dans les revenus des
gares accords et garanties
il faudra avoir probablement au moins 25
ans pour obtenir un chèque et il faudra
surtout ne pas trop tirer d'argent c'est
à dire faire ce que l'on appelle des
découverts en contrepartie de tout cela
et bien un écureuil va offrir cette
carte de garantie elle portera votre
photo et un numéro qui sera reporté sur
le chèque caisse d'epargne s'engageront
sunu s'engager à garantir tous les
chèques émis lorsque leur montant ne
dépensera pas 500 francs dans tous les
chèques de 500 fonds sont sûrs d'être
payés
c'est le cas sera renouvelable chaque
année elle coûtera entre 20 et 30 francs
et pour le reste et bien ces chèques
mais caisse d'epargne seront à peu près
les mêmes que les tchèques finissent par
les banques
c'est une petite révolution car la
concurrence entre l'écureuil et les
banques belle venir plus vite une
affaire douloureuse maintenant
l'histoire d'andré du long un français
qui lie à 5 ans épouse une jeune
canadienne ils ont un enfant lucienne sa
maman l'emmène au canada pour la
présenter à ses grands parents
mais quand le père via les retrouver
devant l'hostilité de sa belle famille
il décide de rentrer en france avec sa
fille et la sphère ne fait que commencer
il ya deux ans et demi la mère à son
tour fait enlever l'enfant l'enfant à
rambouillet et la rapporte au canada la
patrie au canada depuis on aurait dû
l'on n'a pas revu sa fille et
aujourd'hui il a pris une ride décision
celle de se rendre à nouveau au canada
malgré le mandat d'arrêt et les 15
années de prison qui risque de
l'attendre là bas on l'accuse en effet
du kidnapping de son enfant nous sommes
vous le voyez en plein imbroglio
juridique mais derrière il y a un coeur
de père ayant et puis
et en fait toutes les démarches tantôt
gouvernement français auprès du
gouvernement français pas du
gouvernement canadien
j'ai reste de l'ue de me rendre
au canada de mettre à la disposition de
la justice canadienne pour
éventuellement et j'espère faire
réaliser cette condamnation que j'estime
absolument injuste
je compte aussi sur l'opinion publique
canadienne je fais quand même confiance
dans la justice canadienne sur cette
affaire
c'est impensable qu'on condamne un père
à 15 ans de prison pour l'amour de sa
petite fille
ça n'existe pas est-ce que vous êtes
prêts à reprendre la vie commune avec
votre femme
ce n'est pas le but pour lequel je pars
au canada le seul problème c'est mon
enfant je ne peux plus vivre sans ma
petite fille et comment expliquez-vous
latitudes où le changement d'attitude de
votre femme depuis qu'elle est au canada
elle subit les influences de son père
bien entendu elle est attachée à
certaines choses
sa vie la vie de jeune femme riche
il ya de gros moyens je crois que je
crois que c'est l'essentiel pour ma
femme quant à moi et c'est surtout de
retrouver la petite fille ma seule
richesse mathy clean
quant à l'or a atteint un âge 15 ou 16
ans leur a peut-être moins besoin de moi
je ne peux pas mais je veux la voir
grandir et je veux qu'elle est en même
temps une éducation française parce que
lucienne est une citoyenne française
c'est une petite française il faut dire
qu'il n'y ait pas de convention entre la
france et le canada dans les affaires de
cet ordre là jussy ge toujours après sa
condamnation et hier dans le procès qui
l'opposé à simone signoret anne gaillard
fait appel même d'ailleurs que jean
edern hallier un article de louise
berlingot dans le monde cet après midi à
propos du vote des français de
l'étranger sur le quai d'orsay n'a fait
qu'appliquer la loi dit le ministre
étrangère qui relètent quand même une
erreur des irrégularités commises au
gabon à l'étranger le mouvement de
libération de l'iran parle de 100 morts
au cours de manifestations hier et
avant-hier le gouvernement parle lui de
20 morts général reisman reçu par le
président sadate le général reisman et
le ministre israélien de la défense
la commission militaire égypto
israélienne a ouvert ses travaux
aujourd'hui près du caire et j'apprends
qu'il ya quelques minutes sur france
inter ce begin le premier ministre
israélien a déclaré que l'interprétation
française de la résolution 242 du
conseil de sécurité était force
et puis l'italie au moment même où nous
diffusions hier soir vous en souvenez
sans doute ce sujet de patrick clément
sur la déliquescence de la situation
politique est bien de nouvelles
manifestations violentes se déroulait à
rome alors même que la démocratie
chrétienne essayer d'apporter une ultime
solution à la grave crise italienne
rome hier en début de soirée pendant
près de trois heures forces de l'ordre
et militants d'extrême droite ça fera le
point de départ de la violence une
manifestation des néo fascistes pour
protester contre la mort de trois de
leurs camarades a battu samedi par un
commando armé
quoi quoi des voitures et des autobus
sont incendiés au cocktail molotov
répondent des grenades lacrymogènes
des coups de feu sont tirés deux
policiers sont blessés l'écart des
forces de l'ordre sont atteints par une
vingtaine de base
soixante-cinq personnes sont arrêtées
pour la plupart militants d'extrême
droite sur eux on trouvera saint
christaud net
cette nouvelle flambée de violence qui a
déjà fait quatre morts et huit blessés
par balles- à rome depuis noël en encore
plus difficile la situation du
gouvernement chrétien démocrate
cette période de violences d'attentats
et de récession économique
l'italie va encore s'offrir le luxe
d'une crise politique car les dirigeants
de la démocratie chrétienne ils sont
réunis en ce moment dans ce palais du
xviiie siècle à rome doivent répondre à
deux questions
tout d'abord comment faire tomber en
douceur et sans perdre la face le
gouvernement de monsieur andré roth qui
aura duré 17 mois il faudra ensuite
répondre à une question essentielle
y aura-t-il ou n'y aura-t-il pas dans le
prochain gouvernement des ministres
communistes
les dirigeants démocrates chrétiens
doivent tenir compte en premier lieu
d'une opposition à tout rapprochement
avec les communistes à l'intérieur même
du parti
une centaine de députés démocrates
chrétiens sur 262 menace de faire
sécession si on va plus loin en
direction des communistes mais ce n'est
pas tout le président carter a convoqué
son ambassadeur à rome pour bien montrer
que les etats-unis n'apprécierait pas du
tout une participation des communistes
au pouvoir dans un pays aussi intégrée à
l'otan et au marché commun les chefs
historiques de la démocratie chrétienne
sont tous là aldo mort à minto les fans
fine ou giulio andreotti
ils n'ont aucune envie de gouverner avec
les communistes mais peut-on encore
gouverner sans eux en italie soyouz 27
lancé hier par les soviétiques a bien
rejoint saliou ciss il ya à peine deux
heures un événement symbolique puisque
pour la première fois deux vaisseaux
deux équipages ont rejoint la même
station spatiale première tâche des
nouveaux arrivants les banales mais
magnifique apporter leur courrier à ce
qui tourne autour de la terre depuis
plus d'un mois et oui deux hommes en
orbite autour de la terre depuis plus
d'un mois mais cette fois ci ils
attendent de la visite allait entrer dit
youri rahmania encore bienvenue dit
gresh co les visiteurs les voici les
premiers terrains rencontrés depuis un
mois
c'est l'équipage du soyouz 27 voilà le
vétéran à l'eag macarons et le bleu
vladimir gianni beacco en direct pour
les téléspectateurs soviétiques voici
les retrouvailles du cosmos
deux roues de camarades de régiment les
nouveaux occupants du salut où tu ne
sont pas venus les mains vides
ils ont apporté de pâques et du courrier
les journaux et les paquets contenaient
des boissons en tube c'est comme ça
qu'on voit dans l'espace et des
vitamines alors à 300 km au dessus de
nos têtes c'est le top les soviétiques
sont les seuls aujourd'hui dans l'espace
il occupa fonds étudie les stations
cosmique formé comme ici les plusieurs
vaisseau en orbite terrestre
les américains eux attend la navette ce
sera un et prochaine
mais d'ici là les soviétiques ont
beaucoup progressé pardon pour la
qualité des images mais vous avez du
hooligan de tout là haut les sports
maintenant avec l' annonce enfin d'un
circuit motocycliste en ile de france
pour remplacer le dangereux circuit
improvisé de rungis paul dijoux a
annoncé la construction de cet anneau à
trembler les gonesse dans la région
parisienne
et puis la composition de l'équipe de
france de rugby qui doit affronter les
anglais dans dix jours au parc des
princes et trois changements que nous
vous donnions des d'hier soir avec roger
couderc était bon à savoir vous le voyez
l'arrivée de gourdon qui remplace harris
celle de bélascain qui en place sans
galli et puis galion à la place de furu
mais il faut ajouter un quatrième
emplacement beaucoup plus inattendu
celui là celui de rome à l'ouverture par
bernard viviès d'agen et qui en
apprenant son élection là je parle de
jean pierre romeu a déclaré désormais
pour moi l'équipe de france c'est fini
et je crois que nous serons très très
nombreux à regretter le départ
volontaire de furu et celui vous le
voyez involontaire de roms eux deux
joueurs d'une très grande élégance je
troll
enfin notre confrère de france soir font
si sujet est mort hier après un coma de
2 mois provoquée par une chute en vélo
lors du championnat de france des
journalistes français sujet avec 48 ans
il avait couvert 22 tours de france pour
le compte de france soir la rédaction
d'antenne de l'ue rangera un hommage
particulier dans stade 2 dimanche
prochain la météo maintenant vous allez
le voir le matin des pluies et de la
neige sur les régions de l'est et du sud
est en cours de journée un temps
variable et plus frais sur l'ensemble du
pays alternance d'éclaircies et averses
de pluie et de neige
en force sur le pourtour méditerranéen
vous le voyez vous avez deux rendez-vous
avec l'actualité
à 22h55 la dernière édition qui vous
sera présenté par patricia charles
holley et puis tout de suite après ce
journal je voulais dit l'émission cartes
sur table le premier ministre raymond
barre vous le voyez est déjà au studio
101 à la maison de la radio
le temps d'une page de publicité nous le
retrouve voilà ce journal est terminée
tout à fait maintenant prenons de
l'équipe de la rédaction d'antenne 2 qui
m'a aidé à composer
je souhaite une excellente soirée
bonsoir à 2